she's right my eyebrows are a problem
there that's the problem it's got to be
my eyebrows hi my name is Alaina and
today I'm going to tell you the story of
how my mom taught me never to over pluck
your eyebrows and how ultimately that
taught me that you don't have to listen
to what anyone else thinks of you I grew
up in Colorado Springs in a very wealthy
white neighborhood middle school is
around the time I started noticing like
I was different because I was Asian and
I was Jewish and seventh grade is hard
it's like you're all decided in this
like new school and maybe you don't have
the same friends as you did in
elementary school and all of a sudden
it's like so many more kids and you're
just trying to like find your place
again a lot of those people were like a
lot of those kids were very wealthy very
privileged big-ass my mom was like
different than the other moms in the
neighborhood like she looked different
she was different she came here from
China and all the women around we're
here were like very white and said
people things like we don't like
California because there's too many
Asians there you know what I mean it's
like there was this thing in like the
place that I grew up where like even the
nice people were probably still a little
racist like in my family we just had to
be okay with being a little bit other I
remember very distinctly in seventh
grade feeling like I didn't know who my
friends were because I was kind of like
not fitting and and like I had made like
a very conscious decision that like
popularity didn't necessarily matter to
me but at the same time like I felt very
lost socially because I was kind of like
where do I fit in my experience was
bullying was pretty limited on the whole
and I think I skated through relatively
easily I don't want to say it was hard
to bully me but like I had a nice
combination of like invisibility plus if
you did catch me I'd shown a little bit
like there was nothing really to do you
know I know some people's lives are
absolutely ruined by it like their
mental health their wellness into their
20s and 30s like people are damaged by
bullying I think there were experiences
I had where I just felt very other
that has lingered and stayed with me
this instance that I'm going to talk
about really was like one of the bigger
instances of like straight-up bullying I
think I had like so many other infamous
bullying stories this encounter took
place in a locker room seventh grade
girls locker room you're like changing
for gym you've got like your days of the
week underwear on and like some girl
over there is wearing a thong and you're
like oh my god I was in the locker room
and there was this girl and she was one
of those like perfect popular girls and
she's like so tiny but somehow she's
already has big boobs we weren't really
friends like we didn't engage that much
but for some reason this on this day in
the locker room she just decides to like
come up to me and start talking to me
very loudly and around everyone else
like about how my eyebrows are like so
bushy and like I need to think about
plucking them it's just like really
making me super self-conscious and I
never really thought about it before
we're all like half naked in the locker
room like you're just already in like
such a vulnerable state where like
someone is attacking anything about you
anything about your body in this place
where you feel super exposed you're
gonna feel messed up like you're not
gonna feel safe you're not gonna feel
okay this like very tiny perfect blonde
girl all of a sudden is just coming at
me and I already feel other I already
feel lost I already feel like I'm like
kind of like alone in an ocean and I was
just like she's right my eyebrows are a
problem there that's the problem it's
got to be my eyebrows I don't really
remember like even how I reacted in that
moment maybe I think knowing me I was
probably like oh my god thank you for
that tip you know I go home and I like I
need tweezers and my mom's like why do
you need tweezers and I'm like because I
have to like take care of this mess
is absolutely mess on my face and my mom
was like no she was like let's do some
guidelines if you're gonna tweeze like
you can get that like tiny stray one
that's like right there maybe like that
second one that's right there and then
you're done you don't play with the
shape you don't play with the thickness
my mom also had like an iron fist and I
was absolutely not gonna disobey her
rules even about plucking my eyebrows I
got them a little maintenance regimen
going like a nice like you pluck three
hairs every three weeks
basically that's still my maintenance
routine and I don't really give a like
truly I've been blessed with these
beautiful eyebrows and my mother was
right changing them for a bully yeah you
don't need it whenever asked someone
asked me this question like what's the
best piece of advice anyone ever gave
you I always tell them this like it is
like my go-to line like my mom told me
not to over pluck my brows and I stand
by it I am glad that my mother like
enabled me to be other and like to to be
fully myself in a place that like really
didn't want me to be myself I got to be
that asian kid who brought like weird
Asian food to lunch I mean like your
food smells funny and I'm like oh it's
better than your cheese sandwich like
and everyone's always like man that's a
stereotypical story and I'm like no
that's my reality like I wasn't gonna
look like any of the girls in the locker
room I just I was not gonna be this tiny
perfect blonde thing I just never was
going to be her and I am really glad my
mom gave me the tools to be okay with
not being her there are larger lessons
to be taken out of this which are like
you don't need to change yourself for
anyone and you shouldn't if you feel
like this pressure to look a certain way
to make other people happy you just need
to reconsider like why is that person
telling you to do that that's not about
you that's about them my eyebrows were
by no means unreasonable I'll say
they're and even if they were like you
[Music]